اذا مشاهدينا نواصل هذه التغطيه للتطورات
في السودان حيث قال المتحدث باسم الجيش
السوداني ان القوات المسلحه استولت على
جميع مقرات قوات الدعم السريع في ام درمان
بكامل اعتادها والياتها واسلحتها التي
خلفها المتمردون وراءهم اثناء هروبهم من
هذه المواقع وكانت مصادر من الجيش
السوداني قالت للجزيره ان قوات الجيش قصفت
معسكر الصالح بام درمان التابع للدعم
السريع بالمدفعيه الثقيله كما نقل مراسل
الجزيره عن شهود عيان سماعهم ذوي السلاح
في منطقه الفتحات ام درمان غربي الخرطوم
وقالت لجنه اطباء السودان ان 26 شخصا على
الاقل قتلوا واصيب نحو 200 في انحاء
البلاد نتيجه القتال اضافت اللجنه انه لا
يمكنها تاكيد ان جميع القتل والجرحى
مدنيون وافادت مصادر للجزيره بتجدد
الاشتباكات العنيفه قرب مصفاه الخرطوم
ومقر تصنيع الحربي بمنطقه الجيل شمالي
العاصمه وقال مصدر في الجيش السوداني
للجزيره ان قوات الجيش تنشط العاصمه بحثا
عن قوات الدعم السريع الفاره من المعارك
حسب قوله وقالت الخارجيه السودانيه ان
القوات المسلحه تصدت للقوى المهاجمه وطهرت
مطار الخرطوم ومحيطه من جانبها قالت قوات
الدعم السريع انها سيطرت على القياده
العامه للجيش ورئاسات الفرق في دارفور
والملاحه الجويه في عموم السودان